in Logan our titular hero has lost two
stepper to he's grizzled he's hard and
at 140 years old he now faces his most
formidable challenge yet figuring out a
smartphone seriously this guy fought in
World War one you know that every selfie
he's taken has a summited and that he
sent Cyclops like 3,000 notifications
from farmville
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that mixes science with
superheroes and only gets better with
age you know what else only gets better
with age Wolverine apparently because
Logan is great it wasn't just a good
superhero movie it was a good movie that
features superheroes you should
absolutely go see it both for that
reason and because this episode is
chock-full of minor spoilers you've been
warned enter at your own risk
alright so now let's talk about what
really struck me about Logan he's older
he's weaker and his healing factor is
both slower and less powerful than it's
historically been the explanation that
Logan gives us in the movie is that his
adamantium skeleton is poisoning him
and though I really like the movie
something about that explanation for his
sudden old manaf ocation didn't just add
up for me I mean why now why wouldn't
the all-powerful Wolverine have seen any
side effects from his adamantium
skeleton for decades only to just now
find that it's so deadly so I rolled up
my sleeves did some research and most
importantly asked my partner Stephanie
who has a background in medical science
to explain all the big science II words
to me and I've come to a conclusion
simply put Logan is wrong I mean yes
he's getting older and his body is
breaking down but it's not because of
the adamantium and we can prove it with
science first it's important to set a
few things straight for those of you who
aren't rabid MCU aficionados or who just
always like Charles better thought that
Logan was a bit too mainstream
I mean seriously every x-men movie just
like shoehorns them in somehow even
though it makes no sense I'm looking at
you x-men apocalypse it's important to
distinguish Logan's mutation from
Logan's fancy adamantium implants
mutants have a lot of superpowers that
morph parts of their body but Logan's
genetic mutations only involve some of
what you've seen on-screen genetically
his actual x-men powers are as feral
senses his ultra healing abilities and
six bone claws that are found in his
hands two adamantium that he's so famous
for and that's supposedly poisoning him
in this movie is just an add-on that he
received in a lab back in the 1970s an
event that we see in his traumatic
backstory in other films that's
important to remember because with Logan
we're dealing both with natural DNA
mutations and man-made modifications
that make a heart transplant look like a
walk in the park and you could see why
he'd think that had a mantium is his
problem right I mean it would kill most
people and he probably went onto WebMD
and was like adamantium
yeah that's gotta be it bub by the way
have you ever been to WebMD and tried to
diagnose your own stomachache or
something no one comes out of there with
some simple solution like hey that
corndog made me gassy now you come out
of there diagnosing yourself with
parasitic worms and stomach cancer and
irritable bowel syndrome no just just me
that just me yeah fine
and since Logan is so sure that he has
adamantium poisoning in the movie he
won't even let a doctor diagnose him so
let's at least see if that's plausible
scientifically the short answer there is
surprisingly yes many studies have shown
that in regular human anatomy metal
implants can cause big problems for
people especially over time as people
start to get older if implants cranial
plates in people's heads even your
dental implants become slowly corroded
over time even though we don't think of
this usual stuff in our bodies as being
particularly reactive at a molecular
level our own bodies water and oxygen
slowly oxidize the surface of the metal
and if you've ever looked at a bike left
out in the rain or the Statue of Liberty
you know that metal doesn't like water
plus oxygen because it leads to stuff
like rust
now imagine that in your body for those
oxidized metal molecules that break off
and do all kinds of weird stuff like
keep your bones from absorbing calcium
or mess up the electrical currents in
your heart even though modern medicine
makes implants as stable as possible
there's metal corrosion across every
type of metal stainless steel cobalt
even titanium implants so it's
definitely possible that adamantium
could have the same effects especially
in someone who's had implants as long as
Logan and who has had an entire
skeletons worth in a stop I mean
seriously he is putting grandpa's knee
replacement to shame so then it's
adamantium poisoning right what are we
even doing here because adamantium
poisoning isn't even close to the whole
story first of all we would have no
explanation for the timing of Logan's
decay why now after a hundred plus years
if adamantium had been slowly poisoning
him over time you would think that you'd
see something about it somewhere in the
movies before this if there is a gap in
the timeline between this one and last
one but I already hear you making a very
plausible argument no we wouldn't have
seen adamantium poisoning before this
because of Logan's healing factor
Logan's healing factor would have
covered it up and we would have never
known and you know what your argument is
totally right up to this movie Logan's
healing factor would have been powering
full blast to make sure that any
negative effects of metal poisoning
would heal immediately that's the reason
why Logan is the only character to have
an adamantium skeleton other test
subjects died but the healing factor
kept Logan alive but in this movie
that's no longer captaining we're seeing
everything a hurting Logan from gunshots
to broken glass to even adamantium in
his own body but that means it's not the
adamantium poisoning that's killing him
it's the loss of his healing factor his
genetically given superpower is going
away and just uncovering all the other
problems that he's had the whole time
and this is where Logan is wrong about
what's killing him so Logan's healing
power is gone but how does a member of
the x-men lose their abilities its
genetic
it is literally in every single cell of
their body most of them can't even
choose to turn it off if they want to
like rogue and Cyclops well if we want
to understand why Logan's healing factor
is no longer fully functional we first
need to understand how your own genes
can change over time it's easy to think
that you have the same genes from the
day you're born to the day that you die
that's just a clever ruse that our
biology teachers have been telling us to
get more snack time and the teachers
lounge remove the wool from your eyes
Internet you find that as you age your
genes are actually changing all the time
mutations and your genes happen randomly
about 1 times 10 to the negative 10th
time per base pair in real terms that
means that your whole genome all the
genes in one cell that's about 0.32
mutations every time your cells divide
or about one change to the genome
sequence for every three divisions and
if that doesn't seem like a lot consider
this in adults about 50 million cells
die each day and all of them need to be
replaced and you can imagine for Logan
that number is gonna be a whole lot
bigger every time he catches a machine
gun worth of bullets with his face and
for how big your genome is honestly that
number of mistakes ain't too shabby the
good news is that most of these
mutations are silent they don't seem to
have an effect on anything at least not
by themselves occasionally you get a
mutation that does something really cool
if you're in a Marvel movie it gives you
ice breasts or lasers that
out of your eyes hence the reason the
whole x-men universe exists at all but
those kinds of genetic changes even in
the x-men universe are really rare the
genetic changes that are more common and
what's actually happening in Logan
includes something that's called cell
senescence you know when they say that
someone's going senile it means that
they're going a little bit crazy when
they get old well senescence is like
that for your genes it's the same root
word so you can tell ha
this is a secret grammar episode too
nerdy booyah
when you get older your genes start to
get a little whack and develop a kind of
short fuse see every time your cells
divide your chromosomes get all bundled
up and pulled to their new little cell
homes by things called telomeres the
telomeres look like little DNA lassos or
strings but they're actually just more
DNA attached to the end of the
chromosomes if your chromosomes are like
bumper cars the telomeres are like the
bumpers they're big extra chunks of
extraneous DNA at either end of the
chromosome that buffer it in case
anything bad happens what if your cell
accidentally doesn't copy the whole
strand of DNA it's okay it just chopped
off a chunk of the telomere and that DNA
sequence didn't really matter anyway
these buffers also keep two chromosomes
from sticking together so that your body
doesn't do really weird stuff and you
don't grow that awkward third nipple
halfway through puberty you will not
live that one down in gym class my
friends the only problem though is that
telomeres get shorter and shorter as you
get older and older
remember those telomeres are taking all
the hits for you in there so overtime
those buffers get used up after a
certain number of replications called
the hayflick limit and once those babies
are gone you start to have real problems
now that the bumper car doesn't have
anymore bumpers to it it starts to take
damage every hit causes a dent and
eventually the chromosomes can no longer
replicate at all that's when you start
to see stuff like replication errors
bigger genetic mutations that actually
start to mess up the way your body
functions on a bigger scale this is why
even super marathon runners can't live
forever because no one's telomeres can
stay long and strong for hundreds of
years and it turns out the same is true
for Logan well Logan is clearly able to
do some astounding stuff like replicate
a cell's super fast to heal wounds pop
bullets out stone heart and literally
defy gravity with his hair his healing
factor is a DNA mutation his x-men
mutation which means it can
last as long as his DNA stays intact but
what happens when his cells divide too
many times and his telomeres get too
short to protect that DNA over time
those telomeres are taking a lot of hits
they break or they get copied wrong and
eventually they're not gonna be able to
protect the real DNA that matters now
every time a cell divides which let's
face it is happening in Logan a lot
because of all the healing he has to do
any mistakes that get made are getting
made to real DNA the DNA that's keeping
him alive the very DNA sequence that
gives him his healing powers for most
people when telomere short and we start
to see things like graying hair and
arthritis but for Logan DNA damage to
the sequence giving him his mutant
healing means that he literally can't
stop bullets any more damage to his
x-men gene is giving him a death
sentence
all of a sudden fewer and fewer of his
cells have the healing factor he needs
to maintain his abilities it doesn't
happen all at once which is why we see
his power slowly ramped down instead of
stopping altogether in the movie his old
functional cells are being replaced by
new ones new cells with a new mutation a
slightly altered DNA sequence that
knocks out his super healing abilities
it also makes him susceptible to stuff
like disease or other things that might
be floating around in his body
like for instance 50 years of corroded
adamantium that his healing factor has
been covering up this whole time so in
the end here what's most important is
that it's not actually the adamantium
that's killing Logan he's been dealing
with adamantium in a skeleton for
literally decades and it never bothered
him before he's really dying because his
own genes are breaking down and his
x-men mutation is being damaged one or
two base pairs in that x-men DNA
sequence have been changed mutated so
that it's no longer able to save him in
short a DNA mutation gave Logan his
powers and now a mutation due to old age
has taken them away that means that in
the end the real thing that's killing
Logan is irony but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cut but you
know what superpower Logan has that
didn't go away with age incredible
facial hair I mean old man Logan is
looking a bit scruffy throughout the
movie first because he didn't have a
razor
that abandoned water tower where he kept
Charles and then there's the scene at
the end where all the kids are cutting
his beard using scissors what are you
thinking
superhero sideburns need the best
treatment they need
the Dollar Shave Club treatments first
you order Dollar Shave Club online and
boom delivered right to your door even
if that door is an abandoned water tower
in the desert it is so fast and easy
which is especially important when
you're on the run Wolvie and the quality
of these razors is top-notch
they are awesome seriously it is like
the nicest razor I have ever owned heavy
duty and for a fraction of what I pay
for the flimsy cheap ones in the store
so no more rusty old pairs of scissors
there Logan it's just the smarter choice
fast and with great quality at a great
price
honestly it's why I made the switch to
give my superhero smoothness the
treatment that it deserves and you too
can give yourself the superhero
treatment by following the special link
given only to us theorists you see it on
screen right now it's
dollarshaveclub.com slash film theory
there's also a link in the description
that you can click for just $1 $1 you
get your first month and that's any
razor any razor in their entire lineup
so pro tip order the executive like I
said it is the single nicest razor I
have ever bought myself and it's only a
dollar plus it comes with four refills
I used to think that shaving was just
another one of those daily chores that
you have to do but Dollar Shave Club
really makes the difference it makes it
fun to shave and with a heavy duty razor
like the executive I truly do feel like
a superhero and you know what you
deserve to feel that way too damn it so
click the link in the description or go
to our special URL dollarshaveclub.com
slash film theory and get your first
month for a dollar there's no special
fees you're not committed to anything
you can cancel anytime you want just try
it you'll be glad that you did and hey
if you do happen to shave your face
Wolverine style so make that pick on
Twitter I would love to use it in a
future episode so anyway that's all I
got to say for today so now if you'll
excuse me there's a tale as old as time
with my name on it I'll see you next
week click the link